Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker has the unenviable
task of wrapping up the latest Star Wars﻿
trilogy, uniting a fanbase that's become increasingly
divided, and concluding the decades-spanning,
so-called Skywalker saga. That's a lot for
one film to manage. Does it pull it off? Well…yes
and no.
The Rise of Skywalker should've been Leia's
movie. Han Solo got the spotlight in The Force
Awakens, and Luke Skywalker's story dominated
The Last Jedi. With The Rise of Skywalker,
it was Leia's turn. Unfortunately, Carrie
Fisher's tragic death in December 2016 made
a big Leia showcase impossible, forcing J.
J. Abrams to cobble together an arc for the
princess-turned-general from old outtakes.
It's not perfect. Leia's dialogue is noticeably
vague, and it's obvious that Abrams is using
a stand-in when Leia's face is hidden. She
doesn't have any standout moments, the climax
of her arc is a little vague, and much of
her plotline is carried by other people talking
about her, not what she actually does.
However, it works pretty well, and it's much
bigger than a cameo. Leia is in multiple scenes,
and she has a complete arc in the movie. Obviously,
it would've been better if Carrie Fisher were
still around to give Leia the send-off she
deserves. Given what Abrams had to work with,
though, Leia's final on-screen appearance
is significantly better than we expected.
The last entry in the Skywalker saga begins
at a breakneck pace, and it doesn't slow down
to breathe until the film's final minutes.
In order to set up its endgame, The Rise of
Skywalker introduces new characters, new planets,
new gizmos, and new ideas so fast that it's
impossible to keep track of them all. Every
new plot thread introduces a dozen questions
that Episode IX simply doesn't have time to
answer.
While reports differ depending on who you're
talking to, it seems pretty clear that Disney
and Lucasfilm didn't plan this new Star Wars
trilogy out from the beginning. In The Rise
of Skywalker, that decision catches up with
them. The first half of the movie, while full
of action, is mostly set-up for the second
half. It would've been a lot better if some
of those ideas that suddenly show up in Episode
IX had been seeded throughout the previous
two movies.
"I have been every voice…you have ever heard…inside
your head."
As it is, however, one film has to do all
of the heavy lifting, and there's not quite
enough room. Returning characters like R2-D2
and Rose Tico barely make an impact. New characters,
like Dominic Monaghan's Beaumont Kin and Naomi
Ackie's Jannah, hardly register at all.
It all makes for a very bloated and unsatisfying
viewing experience. There's a version of this
movie that's much tighter, but, unfortunately,
it's not the one we got.
You know who steals practically every single
scene he's in in The Rise of Skywalker? C-3PO.
"Oh, they fly now!"
For one, Luke's fussy protocol droid is funnier
in Episode IX than he's ever been. But he
also proves surprisingly vital to the movie's
story. Even in A New Hope, C-3PO is mostly
around to translate for R2-D2. This time,
C-3PO's translation skills are instrumental
in moving the plot forward. If you told us
a few years ago that Episode IX would have
us tearing up over C-3PO, a lifelong comedic
relief character, we wouldn't have believed
you. And yet, here we are.
Did you like The Last Jedi? If so, sorry.
The Rise of Skywalker does a very good job
dismantling pretty much everything that movie
put down. Supreme Leader Snoke's early demise?
As it turns out, he wasn't really that important.
The near-extinction of the Resistance? It's
only temporary. When we rejoin them, they've
found a lot of new recruits. Rey's parents?
We'll put it this way: They were definitely
somebody.
The Rise of Skywalker buries its predecessor
in a way that feels petty, sacrificing lots
of setup in unsatisfying fashion. The only
thing from Episode VIII it really keeps are
the Porgs.
Finn, Rey, Poe, and Kylo Ren are the best
things about the new Star Wars trilogy. Even
when the script lets them down, these actors
are so charismatic that it's fun just to watch
them run around, quip, bicker, and get into
trouble.
The Rise of Skywalker gives us a lot of that,
and it's just as fun as you'd expect, even
though Finn still doesn't have much of an
arc.
Ultimately, though, the movie hinges on the
relationship between Rey and Kylo. Thankfully,
Ridley and Driver are more than up to the
task. The chemistry that the duo shared in
The Last Jedi is cranked up to 11 here, and
the two actors carry the movie. Given how
bonkers the plot is, that's a massive feat.
Going into The Rise of Skywalker, fans had
some major questions. Now that it's out, they
still do. We never learn how Palpatine came
back to life, he just…is. Rey's true nature
comes out of nowhere and isn't adequately
explained, and many key plot points are glossed
over completely. The movie constantly tells
us that things happened, but it doesn't tell
us how or why.
You may recall that The Force Awakens did
the same thing.
"Where'd you get that?"
"A good question, for another time."
Granted, some of the Disney-produced spin-off
materials offer a few clues. But viewers shouldn't
have to do extra research to understand the
basic plot of a movie, no matter how much
Disney wants that to be the case.
Best: A fitting conclusion
J. J. Abrams went big with The Rise of Skywalker,
and if he didn't quite stick the landing,
he certainly at least tried. It's a movie
that's full of spectacle. The dogfights, the
lightsaber duels, and the blaster battles
are bigger than anything we've ever seen in
a Star Wars movie before. And the Easter eggs,
cameos, and nods to past Star Wars films pop
up everywhere.
It's hard to think of a better tribute to
Star Wars, especially given the final scene,
which takes us back to where everything began.
The Rise of Skywalker is bold, ambitious,
convoluted, messy, hopeful, overwrought, and
complicated. In other words, that's Star Wars
in a nutshell.
This is it. Luke, Leia, Han, C-3PO, R2-D2,
and Darth Vader are done. For now at least,
it appears we finally know how this story
ends.
The same seems to be true for our new heroes,
too. None of the main actors involved with
the sequel trilogy seem particularly keen
on coming back for more, and given The Rise
of Skywalker's definitive ending, it's hard
to imagine that their future adventures will
be quite as exciting as the one that just
concluded.
True, Star Wars isn't going anywhere. Disney
will crank out new material set in a galaxy
far, far away for decades to come. Still,
it's just not going to be the same without
our old (and newer) friends at the helm. Thanks
for the memories, folks. May the Force be
with you.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one.